an island nine miles off the coast of
Nagasaki was once one of the most
densely populated places in the world
it's now abandoned home to no one and it
is slowly crumbling into the sea the
Mitsubishi Corporation found an island
that was sitting above an enormous coal
deposit coal was the main source of fuel
for Japan so they immediately began to
mine it to support all of the miners
they had to build a city and to protect
them from the constant storms that
ravaged it and to build an enormous sea
wall surrounding the entire thing they
were shaped a little bit like a ship and
it gave this an island its nickname
Gunkanjima or battleship island 1941
this tiny one kilometer slip of land was
producing over 400,000 tons of coal a
year thousands of miners had been
brought there to mine deeper and deeper
into this underground coal deposit but
the island has a dark history which is
that many of the miners were Chinese or
Korean prisoners of war brought there
during World War two forced to mine
under dangerous and desperate conditions
it's estimated that at the end of the
war 1,300 miners had lost their lives
they had either been killed in mining
accidents died of the illnesses that
came along with the work or some of them
had just jumped over the edges of the
sea walls trying to swim back to safety
even after the war Japan still needed
coal to power its economy and the
Mitsubishi Corporation was more than
happy to comply the mine was dug even
deeper and buildings were put up to
house all of the workers at the
Mitsubishi Corporation brought in by the
1950s the entire island was a kind of
company town complete with pinball
parlors hairdressers schools bars there
was even a brothel the island was so
small that it was said you could walk
from one side to the other and less time
than it took to finish a cigarette and
the island was jam-packed with people
there almost 1,400 people per square
hectare making it one of if not the most
populated place in human history but by
1974 it was all over the middle
vishi corporation and slowly been
letting workers go and in January of
1974 they held a closing Hashima
ceremony in the town has been entirely
abandoned since then this island has a
lot of names the forced laborers who
work there called a jail Island or Hell
Island the mainlanders because it's been
abandoned for so long
refer to it as ghost island but for me
the name that's most poetic is based on
the fact that the island was so
completely built up so covered in
concrete that it was called Midori naxi
Shima or the island without grain but
after 40 years of abandonment as these
concrete apartment buildings has slowly
started to collapse not Island without
green is starting to have a few shoots
peek through the concrete subscribe here
and watch more videos here so from 1974
to 2009 the island was totally
off-limits but it slowly been opening up
in 2013 Google sent a street view team
to Hashima island and so you can
actually now go and walk around through
the abandoned streets of the island you
can even look inside the buildings in
2015 the island was officially accepted
as UNESCO World Heritage Site after
Japan owned up to the dark history of
forced labour